- Your husband was on,
and I gotta be honest with you,
Tom might talk as much as I do,
and that is a lot.
(Rita laughing)
When we were interviewing,
I was like, "I have met my match.
"Challenge accepted, universe."
- Throw it down.
The gauntlet is down.
- But you're chatty, too, though,
but do you mind it?
Or are you kind of like,
- No, no.
"Whew, that's a lot."
- Look, Tom and I, that
was one of the things
that when we met, we
just got along instantly
because first of all, I
love a good storyteller.
So anybody who can tell a good
story, I'm down with that.
And I don't know.
My family was very vocal growing up,
so we were--
- Hence, the Greek.
- Hence, the Greek thing,
(Kelly laughing)
exactly, like talking in food.
That was pretty much our whole existence.
No, I love that.
He makes me laugh all the time.
I think that's--
- He's a great storyteller.
- He is a really good storyteller.
- I was like this the whole time,
and I was like, "Oh God,
I'm interviewing you."
Yeah, I was like,
(Rita laughing)
"Aah, I forgot."
I was just listening.
- We're gonna have you
guys over for dinner,
and we can tell lots more stories.
- Oh my god, it was great.
I think the thing that's
great about both of you,
meeting both of you backstage,
you're super duper famous,
but you're super duper chill,
and that doesn't always happen.
So congratulations on
being normal. (clapping)
- Thank you!
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
- That doesn't happen all the time.
- But I think the same thing about you.
I was asking you backstage,
"How do you do everything that you do?"
I'm completely
mesmerized by it.
- You're like me though.
I just listed a thousand jobs you have.
(laughing)
I was like, "What?"
We have found ourself.
We have found each other.
- But you know what, I love it.
I love doing what I do.
I feel really blessed
to be able to do it,
- [Kelly] Amen.
- and as I continue to do it...
I've been working since I was
14 years old in this business,
- and I had a job here--
- [Kelly] Wow!
at this studio when I was a teenager
at this music concert venue
called the Universal Amphitheatre.
Now it's the Harry Potter ride.
Have you been on it?
(audience laughing)
People used to sing there.
- Yes, I have been on it.
I did get very nauseous.
(Rita laughing)
I'm not into simulation.
- No, no, no.
It's hard.
- I was like, "Oh my god,
"the Dementors are going to kill me."
(laughing)
So what do y'all do, though,
to get away from it all?
Do you do theme parks
like that, or do you--
- Yeah, we do do theme parks,
but one of the things that we like to do
and probably people don't really
think of us as doing this is camping.
- [Kelly] Why would we
not think about that?
- I don't know, because we live here,
and I think of people who--
- [Kelly] It's a great place
to camp!
- I know.
Yeah, there's tons of places
in California to camp.
But we have a little Airstream trailer--
- [Kelly] I love Airstream.
- And we just hook it up
to the back (laughs) of the truck,
and we take it places.
And it's kinda cool
because sometimes we'll
come into a campground,
and it's night, so
people don't really know.
People are usually asleep by then,
so we just come in, make
a hell of a lot of noise.
(laughing)
- Can you imagine--
- And we're, "Sorry, sorry!"
- The people, though, the next day,
and they wake up, they go out,
they're making their eggs,
and they're like, "What?"
They're looking over, and they're like,
"This just got amazing,
this trip!"
(laughing)